ونحييكم من جديد يسلط اتفاق عوده العلاقات
الدبلوماسيه بين السعوديه وايران الذي تم
برعايه ووساطه صينيه على احترام سياده
الدول وعدم التدخل في شؤونها الداخليه وهو
ما يمثل نقطه مفصليه ومحوريه في تحقيق
الاستقرار الاقليمي الاتفاق جاء ليضع حدا
التوتر بين السعوديه وايران والذي كان سمه
مركزيه في المشهد السياسي والامني في
الشرق الاوسط منذ عام
وتنام بصوره واضحه في السنوات الاخيره
نتيجه السلوكيات وسياسات الايرانيه
العدائيه اضافه الى التدخل في شؤون دول
المنطقه مستشار الامن الوطني السعودي اكد
ان ترحيب الرياض بمبادره بكين تاتي
انطلاقا من نهج المملكه الثابت في التمسك
بمبادئ حسن الجوار وانتاج مبدا الحوار
والديبوبلاسيه لحل الخلافات عدا عن حرص
السعوديه على فتح صفحه جديده تقوم
الالتزام بمبادئ ومقاصد ميثاقين الامم
المتحده ومنظمه التعاون الاسلامي
والمواثيق والاعراف الدوليه وفي تصريحات
سابقه لوزير الدوله لشؤون الخارجيه عدن
الجوبير اوضح انه لا شيء يمنع من فتح صفحه
جديده مع ايران ومن بنائه افضل العلاقات
معها على حسن الجوار وعدم التدخل في شؤون
الاخرين اما وزير الخارجيه السعوديه
الامير فيصل بن فرحان في حديث مع جريده
الشرق الاوسط صرح بان الاتفاق يؤكد الرغبه
المشتركه لدى الجانبين لحل الخلافات عبر
التواصل والحوار
هي نتيجه لمحادثات استمرت لسنتين وصلنا في
نهايتها الى تفاهمات مبنيه على حسن الجوار
واحترام سياده الدول ومعالجه كافه تحديات
الامن الاقليمي من خلال هذا الحوار وان
قناعه المملكه العربيه السعوديه ان الحوار
هو الاسلوب الانجع الى معالجه كافه الامور
اعود من جديد الى ضيوفي وينضم لنا كذلك من
القاهره العميد الدكتور خالد عكاشه مدير
المركز المصري للفكر والدراسات
الاستراتيجيه دكتور خالد اهلا بك معنا
اسمح لي ان ابدا معك ومع هذه النقطه او
هذا الملف من نقاشنا عموما السعوديه تؤكد
على
المحافظه واحترام حسن الجوار في مفاهيم
السياسه والعلاقات الاستراتيجيه ما الذي
يعنيه الحفاظ على حسن الجوار الذي يبدو
بانه كان مفقود في السنوات الاخيره
[موسيقى]
تحياتي لحضرتك
وتحياتي للساده الضيوف والمشاهدين جميعا
اعتقد ان من اهم المبادئ الاساسيه هو
احترام سياده
الدول المجاوره جغرافيه واحترام الاعراف
والتقاليد الموجوده في الاقليم بشكل
تام وبشكل كامل يعطي
انطباع مريح لدى هؤلاء بان الدول
تتجه ناحيه المشاركات ناحيه التعاون ناحيه
التبادلات التجاريه لعمل الاستثماري
والاقتصادي المستقر والمتنامي المصالح
المتبادله
نقطه في غايه الاهميه وهي عدم التدخل في
شؤون هذه الدول بصوره او باخرى عدم اجراء
تحالفات مع فصائل او مع كيانات من داخل
الدول بل ان تكون العلاقات مع
راس الدوله ومؤسسات الدوله الرسميه والبعد
عن دعم اي
فصيل او نزاعات قد تعتري بعض من الدول حسن
الجوار يلزم الدوله الموجوده في منطقه بها
هذا الشكل او هذا النمط من النزاعات
الداخليه في الدول ام تحترم الدوله الجاره
هذه النزاعات بنفسها عن الدخول لمسانده
طرف لصالح طرف اخر واشياء من هذا القبيل
الذي تتداوله
الاروقه الدوليه طوال الوقت وتحاول ان تحث
الدول على ان تلتزم بقواعد القانون الدولي
وان تكون العلاقات الدبلوماسيه في اطارها
القانوني المتعارف عليه الذي يضمن مصالح
الجميع وان يكون لكل دوله شانها في اداره
مسؤولياتها واعتباراتها الامنيه استاذ
سامي الى اين مهم وضع مفهوم حسن الجوار
كمبدا لانجاح هذه الاتفاقيات وما الذي يجب
ان يحترم لتحقيق هذا المبدا هل فقط الجانب
الامني ام ان هناك جوانب اخرى عليها ان
تكون حاضره ان تحترم لانجاح الاتفاقيه ومن
خلالها البناء عليها
الحقيقه انا اتصور انه هناك شق ثلاثي يعني
لو اتينا شرعا نجد ان هذه التداخلات قد
اضعفت الدول الاسلاميه الدول التي فجرت
بسبب هذه المداخلات هي دول الاسلاميه
وبالتالي بهذا التدخل به اضعاف للاسلام
يعني اعتقد ان ايران
لا تود اضعاف الاسلام انما ناتج العمل هو
اضعاف للاسلام ضعفت العراق وضعفت سوريا
وضعفت لبنان وغيرهم واليمن الحال كذلك هذا
من الجانب للجانب الانساني معروف ان قضيه
الجوار سواء كانت للافراد او للدول قضيه
هامه انه دائما ان احسن علاقتي بجاري حتى
عندما اريد امر ما ساجد الدعم والمؤازره
وفي هذا السياق نعلم ان الدول الخليجيه
بامكانها وبقدراتها اللي ذكرت منذ قليل
قاربت مستوى دول العالم الاول ان تساهم
وتساعد ايران
طرق عديده يعني اليوم القدوه بالتعليم
والصحه والاستثمار والصناعه وغيرهم وغيرهم
موجوده بالخليج بالتالي يمكن لنا كجيران
لايران ان ندعم ايران يبقى الشق الدولي
والقوانين والمواثيق الدوليه قضيه التدخل
بشؤون الدول الاخرى يرقى بالمفهوم الدولي
الى اعلان حرب حتى ان صدام 79 في حجه
رائمه الكبرى عندما ايران استعان بهذا
النص وقال ان الحرب بدات قبل شنه الحرب
عبر التدخل في شانه الداخليه او شؤون
العراق الداخليه وبالتالي كل المواثيق وكل
الاعراف الانسانيه
والدوليه تمنع هذا التدخل ناهيك عن ان
التدخل نتج عنه ضرر كبير بالمتدخل
وبالدوله التي تم التدخل بشؤونها بيودي بس
ان اختم بقضيه مهمه ان هذا التدخل ليس
طريق ذو اتجاهين يعني احنا لم نرى دول
نرى المملكه ولا دول خليجيه تتدخل بالشان
الايراني او بشؤون الدول الاخرى وتنشئ
ميليشيات وغيرها وبالتالي هو طريق ذو
اتجاه واحد متى ما اوقفت او اقتنعت ايران
بان هذا النهج قد جرب لاربعين عام وانتهى
بالضرر بايران بالدرجه الاولى وبالدول
التي تم تدخل بها انا اعتقد جزء كبير من
الاشكال سينتهي ونبدا بصفحه جديده يكون
الكاسب الاكبر بها ايران سواء كان شعبا
حكومه دوله الجميع سيربح من العلاقه
الجديده متى ما كانت هناك جديه بتطبيق
الاتفاقيه مهمه جدا استاذ العنقري نحن
صحيح نتحدث عن مرحله تاريخيه شهدت
اختلافات وخلافات عديده بين الطرفين ايران
والمملكه العربيه السعوديه
وهناك اتفاقيه لحل هذه الخلافات ولكن
التاريخ الثنائي شهد كذلك تقارب وكانت
هناك حتى علاقه تجاريه
استراتيجيه اقتصاديه متينه خلال سنوات ما
اهم القطاعات التي يمكن الحديث عنها في
اطار الجيره وفي اطار تبادل تجاري يفيد
المنطقه
يعني بالنسبه لايران هي ستستفيد من كثير
من المنتجات في المملكه بالذات في مواد
البناء
وايضا بعض المشتقات البتروكيماويه رغم
انها دوله نفطيه وغازيه ولكن ليس فيها
استثمارات كافيه لان تنتج مواد ممكن
استخدامها بالاضافه طبعا الى التبادل
التجاري فيما يخص المنتجات الزراعيه ايران
بلد يعني لديها
اراضي زراعيه ولديها قدره على انتاج زراعي
ضخم اضافه الى المنسوجات
بالاضافه طبعا الى ان العلاقه فيما يخص
قطاع العمره والحج ايضا هذا يخلق فرصه
كبيره لزياده التبادل التجاري من خلال
يعني رحلات على مدار العام تخدم قطاعات
الايواء وقطاع النقل هذا بشكل مبدئي ولكن
ممكن ان تتطور هذه
التجاريه في المستقبل لان السوق الايراني
سوق ضخم ولكن بالتاكيد هو يعاني من سياسات
اقتصاديه
يعني فاشله بنهايه المطاف فاذا ما يعني
تحسنت الاحوال سيكون هذا السوق بالنسبه
لنا سوق مهم جدا لاننا
نستفيد من ميزه القرب الجغرافي عموما
ولذلك سيكون لدينا الكثير من المنتجات
التي يمكن ان نصدرها لهذا السوق عندما
تدخل ايران في مسار
تنميه وانا اعتقد ان الصين يعني دخولها
كوسيط لانها هي التي وقعت اتفاقيه ب 400
مليار استثمار في ايران ولذلك لا يمكن ان
تضخ فيها اي دولار واحد ما لم تتغير ايران
من ناحيه النهج السياسي بشكل عام وانت
وبالتالي الى علاقات تجاريه صحيح ولكن
حضرتك طالما تحدثت عن الصين وكان لك مقال
تحدثت فيه باسهاب عن هذه العلاقه وكيف
يمكن ان تتحقق فرص اقتصاديه من خلال ليس
فقط التقارب ولكن الوساطه الصينيه اسمح لي
ان اسالك حول هذه النقطه نحن نتحدث عن
طرفين ولكن كذلك الطرف الثالث جد مهم
نتحدث عن وساطه صينيه كيف يمكن الاستفاده
من هذه الوساطه اقتصاديا
اولا الاستفاده هي من ان الصين اليوم
اصبحت يعني تضع نفسها كقطب حقيقي ليس فقط
اقتصادي بل بدات تخرج كقطب ايضا مؤثر في
السياسه الدوليه وهذه اول عمليه وساطه من
هذا النوع تقوم بها الصين وبالتالي
مصداقيتها المحك هي بالتاكيد لها اليد
الطول على ايران لان ايران المنقذ الوحيد
لاقتصادها عمليا هي الصين ولم تستثمر حتى
الان من الاربع مئه مليار الى 182 مليون
دولار وهذا بسبب العقوبات على ايران وبسبب
ايضا سياساتها وسوء علاقاتها مع جوارها
وبالتالي فان وجود الصين
كشريك تجاري في الشرق الاوسط ببيئتين
مليار دولار مع دول الخليج ومنها اكثر من
80 مليار مع السعوديه وحوالي 14.6 مليار
فقط مع ايران هذا يعطي الافضليه بان الصين
تريد ان تعزز قوتها في هذا السوق الضخم
الذي يمدها
الطاقه والذي يعتبر ايضا نافذه مهمه لها
ويقربها من افريقيا ومن اوروبا في حال ضخت
استثمارات في البنى التحتيه والقطاعات
اللوجستيه وقطاعات صناعيه مهمه سواء في
الخليج او حتى في ايران ولذلك انا اعتقد
ان هذه الاتفاقيه بنيت على اسس تدعم
امكانيه تطبيقها بشكل كبير لان المصالح
بالنهايه مصالح كبيره ايران تاتي من موقف
ضعف ومن موقف انها بحاجه الى ان تتنفس
اقتصاديا ونحن هنا في الخليج نحن متقدمين
وتربطنا في الصين علاقه قويه وبالتالي
اصبحت هي
الطرف المفضل خصوصا انها هي عضو في مجلس
في دائم في مجلس الامن ولكنها الطرف
الافضل لمثل هذه الاتفاقيه ان تكون وسيط
دكتور خالد هذه التنميه وهذا الازدهار
سنتحدث فيه بعد قليل باكثر تفاصيل ولكن لن
يتحقق الا اذا ما كانت المنطقه امنه
ويقال بانه في السياسه ليس هناك عدو دائم
ليس هناك صديق دائم لم نصل لمرحله الصداقه
ولكن لمرحله الاحترام كيف يمكن لايران
وللسعوديه ان يتحقق الامن من خلالهما في
المنطقه
ولهما كذلك في هذه المرحله بهذه الاتفاقيه
يعني هذه نقطه في غايه الاهميه وربما هي
تمهد المشهد لما هو قادم ولما ينتظره
الجميع
بشكل شفاف تماما المملكه طوال تاريخها
وطوال هذه السنوات كانت لاعب استقرار في
اتجاه الامن الاقليمي
تاريخها ومواقفها في الاقليم تشهد على ذلك
في كثير من الملفات المفتوحه في الاقليم
او حتى على المستوى الدولي لكن بالنظر الى
ايران اعتقد ان الباب الذي فتحته المملكه
باستعاده العلاقات معها في هذه اللحظه
وهذا الترحيب الاقليمي
بانجاز هذه الخطوه اظنها تدفع ايران الى
قدر من مراجعه النفس بشفافيه
والتعامل بواقعيه ومصداقيه مع نتيجه
مشروعها الذي كانت تتبناه طوال الماضيه
وتدرك تماما بواقعيه شديده نحن لا نبالغ
عندما نقول بان المشروع الايراني قد وصل
الى نقطه انسداد كبيره جدا والارقام
والمشهد السياسي والامني يتحدث عن ذلك
بغضوح
ايران تحتاج الى ان تراجع نفسها بشكل كبير
كي تنتقل الى ما بعد استعاده العلاقات مع
المملكه السعوديه ومع دول المنطقه اذا اذا
كان هناك فرصه لذلك مساله اعاده الاعتبار
الى سياسه وسياده الدول وعدم زرع
الاحتقانات المذهبيه التي لم تعرفها
المنطقه قبل هذا المشروع الايراني وهي
نقطه وهي تاريخ حقيقي
العالم كله يتغير فيه فلا يعني لا يوجد
حرج في ان تغير ايران من نهجها بعد ان
وصلت بمشروعها الى هذا المشهد الذي يت
العالم
ومشهد المناطق التي حاولت ايران ان تكون
هذه المناطق والدول الجغرافيه هي مسرح
لهذا المشروع بعد الوصول الى هذه السمعه
على المستوى الدولي من ايران اعتقد ان هذا
الباب الجديد الذي فتح امامها يعطيها فرصه
كي تقدم نفسها بوجه جديد بسياسه جديده
بمشروع توافقي بمشروع يعزز ويدعم من الامن
الاقليمي بدلا من ان يخصم منه او يكون
باعثا للتوتر او الاحتقان او غيره على
فكره مفهوم ايران بين الدوله وثوره ربما
سيكون موضوع نقاشنا غدا همم
اليوم سنتابع مع هذه النقاط التي ادرجناها
في النقاش واعود لكم بعد فصل قصير لنتحدث
كذلك على امكانيات الازدهار امكانيه تطوير
هذه المنطقه من اي بوابات بعد فاصل قصير